freddie peralta toeing the slab for the
crew
and he faces the diamondbacks here today
first time as a starter he's appeared
against him a couple of times
as a reliever back in 2019 1-2
chase that change up down in the way
first strike out for freddie peralta
there you go that change that's really
coming into his own
and the fastball the
slider the
occasional curve ball and then this
pitch and he started to break this one
out off the outside corner and
swinging to the miss
speaking of heat there's some from
freddie peralta
a couple of strikeouts right-hander matt
peacock
very solid in beating the cardinals at
chase field last weekend yeah he's one
of those consistent guys going to be
around the plate he's going to pitch to
contact so the defense has to be on
their toes today daniel vogelback is
going to be the batter
205 for him with three home runs
left center field
gone
out in a line for daniel vogelbeck
right over the yellow line into the
brewers bullpen they've struck again for
another homer well they made the most of
their hits in yesterday's game four home
four home runs
of their seven hits
yesterday and they're at it again
tonight
[Music]
daniel vogel back on a two seaman has
stayed up
when he had the most stress that one
lined in the center jackie bradley jr on
the move and he's able to reach down and
make the catch
he put his head down was running to a
spot the ball died on him he was able to
put on the brakes and make the catch
that's about as much emotion as you're
going to see out of jbj right i mean
kind of looked over yellows and said all
right well whatever i got it and the
bases are loaded two walks an infield
single and now jackie bradley jr coming
to play one ball and no strikes
peacock for jackie bradley jr bouncer
hit to short
ahmed to second for one relay is going
to be
late at first
and the brewers get a run
narvaez scores
on to third goes travis shaw
adamus erased on that 6-4 force
the consistency yet up until this season
but so far
into june and freddie peralta has been
as consistent as they come on the mound
the 1-2 pitch swing and a miss chase the
slider low and away it's another
strikeout for freddie peralta
his fourth of the night and there's two
way now for josh rojas peralta coming
home with a one-two swing and a miss
he climbed the ladder with a fastball at
94.
five strikeouts for freddie peralta
garcia with good speed at first
and the first pitch to narvaez is a line
drive into center field that's going to
get down plugs the gap rolls all the way
to the wall as it gets under the glove
of smith in center around third is
garcia he's going to score and narvaez
all the way into third and now the ball
gets away
and narvaez is going to be awarded home
oh
omar narvaez
with a sharply hit drive into center
smith tried to cut it off before it got
to the warning track
it ended up going under his glove and
all the way to the wall
this should be a triple
and an rbi for narvaez and then an error
allows him to score from third
diamondback's manager tori lavello who
has seen his team play sloppy and
inefficient baseball is letting him have
it he has had enough one-two pitch
swinging to miss got him with a slider
strikeout number six for peralta and
there's one away here in the
diamondbacks four
swinging into this by escobar there's
the seventh strikeout
strikeouts in every start that didn't
take long did it three and two thirds
innings with seven punch-outs already
there's a line drive caught by daniel
vogel back
the spry first baseman
taking an extra base hit away from pavon
smith
well then had the greatest range in the
world but you know a couple of quick
steps and throws the glove out there and
there it was
pitch number 80 in the game coming up
for freddie peralta
got him
high heater in 96.
eight strikeouts
for freddie peralta through
five strikeout number nine for freddie
peralta narvaez has to complete it with
a toss to vogelback freddie
feeling it again here tonight yeah third
strikeout for peralta
on the slider two base runners for
arizona
ground ball third base shaw on the
second hop
throws it across him plenty of time
freddie peralta still yet to allow a hit
for six
four nothing brewers
with 90 plus pitches entering the
seventh inning probably not a complete
game kind of night for freddie peralta
as he brings home the 01 pitch popped
him up
that'll help though from a pitch count
standpoint
narvaez sheds the mask makes the catch
just behind home plate
and there's a couple of pitches in a big
out career high in strikeouts for
freddie is 13. did that in his big
league debut at colorado still one of
the most memorable starts
for any brewer any time
a little flare center field diving
catching out
what a play luis suryas
what a play by louisa
to
protect the no-hitter at this point
wow what a play by release up the middle
a little sinking wider than him
[Applause]
nice
[Applause]
great stab by louisa as freddie peralta
loves it
rolled right side shaw picks throws
seven no hit innings
from freddie peralta 2-0 on pavon smith
two hard-hit balls
liner left field yelling got it one way
the highest pitch count of freddie
peralta's career
oh and two on nick ahmed
one two
ahmed reaches down and dunks it into
left center
and there's the diamondbacks first base
hit of the ball game
freddie peralta takes a no-hitter into
the eighth inning and ahmed breaks it up
that's gonna do it for freddy what are
your performance tonight
freddie peralta's family loves it as
craig council is coming out pat's on the
chest from all of his teammates job well
done for freddie peralta
listen
he digs in batting left hand of the
pitch to him swung on and a high
towering fly ball to right
back in front of the wall out there is
garcia makes the catch both tag
coming in to score his reddick and ahmed
goes to third
and cabrera just missed the three-run
homer three-two
[Applause]
on the 12th pitch of the ad back goes
deep to straight away center
[Applause]
out garcia coming in it's garcia catches
made ball game over brewers have made it
two in a row against the diamondbacks